does that mean that you consider it an
actual genuine emergency well
i would say that that's probably a
question for the department of homeland
security uh who obviously oversees that
an influx of kids
at a rate and a pace um that is going to
require
us to you know make considerations about
where we're going to safely house them
i think jen needs to spend some time
with a border patrol
like we did and live their lives for
just a few hours
i don't think they have a firm grasp on
anything including reality now internal
documents obtained by axios
showing that during the last week of
february border patrol
referred an average of 321 migrant kids
each day to hhs shelters
which is soon they're all soon going to
be at maximum capacity they're about 94
percent
it's actually worse though than this the
washington post immigration reporter
is tweeting that the number of families
and minors arriving
is expected to be the highest in over
20 years and the government will use
hotels
if it runs out of space when's the last
time you went to a hotel
now if it wasn't that bad uh get ready
for this my next guest says that the
bind administration is vastly
undercounting the real extent of this
crisis here now is former senior adviser
to president trump stephen miller
stephen you and i have been talking
about illegal immigration what it's
doing to the country for years and years
and years
but you have a lot of sources in border
patrol as well
they're briefing you about the real
situation on the ground today what are
you hearing
well the administration has publicly
admitted which is rather shocking
that a hundred percent of minors
traveling alone many of them teenagers
are being resettled and released all
throughout the united states all 50
states
but what they're not telling you is that
most
family units are now also being released
too and that's why we're seeing now 4
000 apprehensions a day because word has
spread
not just in central america but
throughout the world that if you come as
a family
or as a minor you're going to be
released that's not being publicly
disclosed so what they're saying
publicly
oh no we're still turning away family
units in reality
the majority of family units are now
being released into the interior of the
country
and a lot of them are going to go into
communities that don't have the hospital
capacity
or the health care resources to deal
with them and that's going to mean
during a pandemic
low-income americans are going to be
denied the health care
resources that they need so this really
exacerbates
a public health crisis in addition to a
national security crisis
well the dhs secretary mayorkas
is a radical he's blaming the trump
administration
big shock for the situation unfolding at
the border
we do not have the capacity now to
address
the asylum seekers claims because that
system was dismantled in its entirety by
the prior administration we have to
address those implications not only for
the benefit of the
of the communities in the united states
but for the migrants themselves
stephen this wouldn't be happening right
would it if
they hadn't rolled back the trump border
policies and rolled out the red carpet
for illegals
the the comment from secretary mallorcas
is an offense
to human intelligence and reason when we
left office
the border was fully secure if you came
illegally
you were detained and you were safely
returned home that is the definition of
border security
that if someone crosses illegally border
agents can apprehend them
and then they can be safely returned to
the country they came from
we had that system in place because we
had deals with mexico
we had deals with central america we
reformed our asylum regulations we
reformed our intake procedures we
expedited return flights home
we had charter flights leaving every
single day to have a safe secure humane
border
he and his fellow political appointees
at dhs
dismantled all of that they dismantled
the most effective
asylum system that had ever been created
in this country
and they launched this border crisis and
he needs to own up to that fact and not
lie to the american people
and not disrespect the ice officers and
border agents
who painstakingly achieved that security
plan and i'll say one other thing
while they're pretending to be
compassionate not only are their plans
deeply injuring american families and
american communities
but they're destroying the northern
triangle guatemala honduras and el
salvador
cannot possibly succeed if this mass
exodus of young people is allowed to
continue
those countries won't have a future
they're sentencing those countries
to generations of poverty and misery
well look this is about exploiting
the labor of these migrants coming
across the border i mean say that
that's just brutally honest this is so a
lot of rich people
can have cheaper landscapers and nannies
and whatever
that's what this is about it's nothing
humanitarian about it there's nothing
compassionate about it it's so rich
people can have cheap labor and
businesses don't have to pay the wages
to american citizens middle class are
suffering and those countries are
suffering to make rich people richer
yeah meanwhile we have 13 uh illegal
immigrants die in this fiery crash
because
human smuggling on the on the rise as
well because of these policies
it's all hideous stephen thank you so
much it's depraved thank you it is